i know that you were attached to doing
or maybe you are doing a rihanna
documentary and a chris cornell
documentary
um can you can you talk about both of
those projects where they're at and what
was it about
the material um the rihanna dock
something i've been working on with her
for
almost four years now um it's coming out
uh amazon's gonna release it um
mid mid quarter summer next year
um sometime sometime hopefully around
the fourth of july
um and it's it's been a really epic
journey spending
the past four years with her and
going from you know so much has happened
uh uh to to our country towards society
since we started this so it's something
that's still ongoing we're still
shooting it
now um and uh i know she's
a remarkable woman who has
you know ev every day seems to to grow
and branch out and
to new businesses and new endeavors um
uh in a rate that's it's almost hard to
keep up with so
um every time we think we're going to
finish the movie
and and put it out she does something
like start a fashion line
uh like fenty um or
her lingerie line or her skin caroline
um
she's just she's she's firing on all
cylinders and she's making new music now
and she's she's having so much success
in business and she's such a
an entrepreneur that we're letting it
grow but
we are gonna try and close it up uh
in the spring and release it in the in
the summer uh
and what about the chris cornell thing
that's that's being kind of put together
now
yeah so chris cornell is uh is
just a doc that we're putting together
now
i don't have a timeline on it yet got it
this is my last question for you
i've spoken to you a few times and every
time i speak to you i bring up the exact
same thing and it's going to continue
today
whether we're doing a friday night like
smoothie no i wasn't going to ask that
i would but we could we could do that i
was just going to say what what do i
need to do to get a rundown sequel
yeah you know you got to like schedule
it for
2030 because dwayne johnson's so busy
right we almost did it and we made the
mistake of writing this
setting the script on alaska and dwayne
johnson's character was going to go to
alaska
and nobody thought that maybe dwayne
johnson a hawaiian boy
doesn't want to be going up to alaska
and filming the tundra so we got to
rethink the script
right whatever whatever we need to do to
get that thing made is